hello your majesty what can I help you
Oh Sal I have such an emergency
I have commissioned a good statue of my
father's head and I'm not sure if it's
the right size oh well well what what is
what is the right size well as you know
in our kingdom we have a tradition of
measuring things in terms of blue fuzzy
squares
yep I'm aware of that I also like to to
measure things in terms of blue fuzzy
squares and by law all good statues in
our kingdom have to be exactly for blue
fuzzy squares tall okay that seems like
a reasonable law so what's what's the
issue well I'm not sure if this statue
is for blue fuzzy squares tall well okay
well let's let's let's calm down I think
I think we can work through this I have
a bunch of blue fuzzy squares here
why don't we why don't we put them next
to the statue and see if they're this if
we're if we are exactly for blue fuzzy
squares tall oh that would be just
wonderful oh here you go here you go
your highness yeah why don't want you
why don't you stack them up oh listen
let me do this okay so that's one two
and blue oh my god this is an emergency
this is only three blue fuzzy squares
tall it is not tall enough oh no what am
I going to do oh wait no wait hold on
hold on it's decide I don't think you
have to panic just yet because when I
look at how you stack them up and it's
actually quite amazing because you
allowed you somehow made these blue
fuzzy squares levitate oh of course how
blue fuzzy squares need to levitate okay
well yeah and that's that's that's neat
but if you really wanted to measure you
need to make sure that you don't have
any gaps over here so so why don't you
try again so let's take these these blue
fuzzy squares out and while you try to
try to measure again okay now that makes
makes all the sense in the world okay so
let me try again
so that's one
you notice I'm not letting them no gaps
here yep yep okay although it's already
well let me keep going so I'll stop
interrupting me okay
okay keep going your highness three and
five oh no no no this isn't all wrong
it's going to be a disaster it needs to
be four not five blue fuzzy squares oh
wait wait your highness I I don't don't
panic it I don't think this is quite
right because you didn't start you
didn't start at the bottom of the statue
you started below the bottom of the
statue and you didn't end at the top of
the statue
you ended above the top of the statue so
it isn't five blue fuzzy squares tall Oh
Sal I'm just so confused can you just do
it for me oh well I think it's better if
you do it yourself just keep keep keep
it in mind start start measuring start
measuring at the bottom of the statue
and stop measuring at the top of the
statue and just make sure that you don't
have any spaces in between okay I'm
getting tired but I'll give it one last
try
yeah I think I think that's a good good
good good idea it's always about making
a good a good effort on things okay here
I go
this is the bottom so I'll stop stacking
there this is the top so I will stop
stacking there okay one two and I don't
want any gaps so two three three and oh
oh
it actually looks just about right it
looks just about right we are exactly we
are exactly four blue fuzzy squares tall
oh this is just going to be a wonderful
addition to the palace thank you so much
well I'm glad to help you your your
highness